nicolas pernikoff il va mieux le grand
manitou de france télévisions et ouais
il est là il fait partie de l'équipe
maintenant il est heureux il est sportif
il est bien peigné on va vers quels
projets au niveau de la coiffure niveau
capillaire
voilà pour l'instant on change rien à
terme il est terminée parce que la norme
et ses numéros non gilbert montagné
j'aime bien mais c'est vrai il a quelque
chose mais l'on sait que ça va vous
emmener tout va bien toujours le coup de
bambou dans l'oeil mais ça ouais
toujours la patate faut qu'ils fassent
je suis parti à 8 cents à l'école c'est
un truc de fou et humer lui olivier
ferrand une forêt des mois à venir
une soirée avec nicolas pernikoff all in
et les rend si tu t'endors pas au bout
de 7 minutes
généralement c'est moi qui m'en donnera
aux petites limites assez haut rhin aux
environs de ceuta des épis tous et moi
ya 20 ans j'en sais me pailler parole on
était à 2 % de part de marché j'espère
bien faire un truc est ce que tu peux
pas appeler une personne de far west
j'ai envie qu'on appelle à nous battre
au divertissement et à faire gérer
nicolas pernikoff c'est unique
franchement j'ai lancé plein de truc qui
colle avec son portable à lui ah ouais
ce n'est pas le connais pas allo connu
pareil
non mais c'est moi que c'est moi elle va
comprendre et gaouaoui donc un double
numéro de quelqu'un d'autre
je pense que lui et vous l'a pas votre
portable si à merde vous alors voilà
votre sim est la numéro de votre bible
on peut regarder maintenant quelqu'un
qui l'a pas et on l'appelle mais voilà
mais on peut l'appeler parfait sur la
tête de ma mère
le téléphone frère c'est bon vous avez
un code c koi jésus-christ 24 dire c'est
mon année de naissance mais c'est 1925
d'injures c'est vrai c'est vrai je pense
qu'il ya un flic quand même un peu plus
des liens j'arrive pas tu peux me le
faire là parce que merci ma chérie tu va
l'appeler savent être payés exceptionnel
talent numéro deux s'est évanouie
non non je n'ai alexandra une jeune àge
partir si jeune et je tiens la fin c'est
parti ça servait une très grosse
rigolade
tu le fais ça y est je laissais du conte
battant lui résine de moi ça m'est tout
cas je l'avoué elle massage bas possible
et qui m'a foutu seul adam l'élection
bordel de merde mais c'est quand même un
moussa rêve and i apèl l'attraction
numéro mais oui j'ai quand même un
modèle petite passoire
alors bakassi il va faire passer numéro
jennifer numéros et le numéro 10 là où
tu t'es pas six mois au dessus des monts
franchement franchement je trouve qu'il
a sélectionnés je trouve qu'il raconte
est là qu jamais ça non une farce
le mec a lancé écoute c'était une femme
c'était un proc
oui allô c'est un sage me et non non on
préfère prêtre j'adore ça c'est ça la
réponse amis sont assez l'ipo la turn
off
j'ai regardé envoyé spécial hier mais
bons rails combler ce que vous faites
oui j'en sais oubliez pas et part on
était à 2 % de part de marché fignon
était à 24%
vous avez pensé quoi vous nommez dit non
pardon excusez moi et c'est de remplacer
les pardons vous annoncer quoi vous vous
avez vu l'état des hôpitaux par exemple
la graine
[Rires]
nicolas pernikoff ils ont mis de photos
à la volée au directeur at elle permet
aux e mails à la pause